好了 那個謝謝
就是我覺得這段時間一個多月以來 年底以來
我覺得市場的觀點還是我一直是比較一致的
就是整體來看 你在美聯儲降息之後會進入一個真空的時期
那麼在這個真空時期裡面結合前一段時間美國政府官們
包括一季度的話數據會比較差
然後財政政策 貨幣政策其實都有點缺啥
就是公司 earnings的確實
這種情況下市場就會比較不穩定
也不會說一定會大跌吧 就是會比較不穩定
我一直覺得這個時候是可能現倉的時候
就今天我們可能多花一點時間講一講
然後我的看法其實沒有變化
然後大家有些什麼問題呢
我覺得可以多花一點時間的做一下Q&A
然後我總結一下上兩周吧
其實市場跟我們預期的還是比較相似
就我們一方面對明年市場整體宏觀形勢是比較看好
對於科技股帶領的其實美國的市場尤其比較看好
然後我們也看好這整體的token的需求
包括現在看到的所有的token的需求和這個市場需求
後面可能的投資
其實我們都沒有看到特別大的問題
但是現在在這一個月裡面是一個真空期
就讓我們一直覺得美聯儲降息完成以後
就是一個真空期
就是你其實手上沒有牌
12月22號公司的拜拜基本上都結束
所以從流水上來說
你也沒有很多的強制金的錢要買進來
從整個基本面來看
美國的BBB法案後面能夠退稅出多少錢
現在退稅被delay了以下之後就算退出去
後面的政策其實也是空權
貨幣政策也有點空權
所以這個三重情況下
市場就是現在在調整
原來有可能調整的都有可能調整了少
但我們能夠看到的是AI公司的估值其實並沒有問題
下一週這一週美國要出一些比較重磅的經濟數據
為什麼放這個godlock呢
就是godlock代表的經濟數據現在很了難
就是你不管是好和不好
市場都會很predator都會很敏感
你必須要正正好好不溫不火然後才可以
那麼後面幾個經濟數據
其實主要為什麼大家比較關注
因為它其實在政府關門之後
缺失了很長時間一個比較靠譜的數據
我們之前就業數據一直靠了ADP
就靠著那個私營部門包括的數據
其實這個數據並不像能放payroll這麼精準
所以其實美聯儲你要去做決定
最後看的還是能放MPF
今天晚上要報11月份的能放payroll
這個數據根據以前的ADP數據來估計的話
這個數據不會特別好
那麼我覺得現在可能從基本面數據來說
可能還沒有到底那個11月份肯定不是到底的
12月份1月份這些經濟數據都有可能會不好
甚至到2月份都有可能不好
但這不代表市場會跌到那個時候
市場跌一定遠遠超前於數據到底
但是數據開始變差
這就是數據變差可能是一個市場往下的信號
但數據變得很差
那市場差不多到底了就是
那麼11月份的數據
然後加上那個星期四的時候就是CPR
其實一方面大家其實也在擔心通常
因為美聯儲在上一次上週的降息的時候
已經表現出比較大的分歧了
特別是對於明年
你看明年的分歧還是很大
就是對26年的這個中位
雖然說中位數的降息也沒有變化
但是這個FIDLE出來還是大家兩邊的那個descent
我們看到的descent就是那個就是
叛變者就是聯儲裡面的分歧是很大
所以通脹也是會是一個大家比較環境的數據
就是CPR到略會怎麼樣
失業率就怎麼樣
上一次的話
那個我們現在因為美聯儲上次
美聯儲的講話是JPAL相對來說是比較軟弱的
因為JPAL講到幾個
雖然他despite他一邊有人希望降了更多
一邊有人下期希望不要講一些
那麼但是他講話相對來說是比較軟弱
他第一個說就是 job creation
就是我們看到的經濟數據可能相對來說
低估了6萬人每個月的就業
這個其實數據蠻嚴重的
我們其實對於失業的情況相對來說是比較低估的
第二個我們要準備好進入一個付的那個付就業的情況
就經業就業人說可能變付
那這個實際 job creation是付的
那麼這個就代表著其實聯儲
第一個他沒有說預分不降息
他等於是open door for January cut
就月份有可能還是可以降一下
第二個就是說
第二個其實就是他表示的
他這個意思就是我現在主要關注的點還是就業
那麼最近聯儲有很多討論
就是到底是那個
Kamal還說能不能上去
能不能最後拿到Trump的nominee
因為Trump也其實中間也有點想變掛的意思
但是我覺得不管是哪個 fat chairman
他最終在2026年的時候都是相對來說比較軟弱的
就是相對來說都會比較割的
因為在26年的時候
我們一方面要面臨前面的就是關稅
就Trump上臺以後做了很多的那個政策的調整
包括關稅包括政府關門
這個是他被動的被調整
那個政府關門和關稅
那這些對經濟基本面其實都是有一些往下的影響
這個影響都是要之後
就不是說我當季就是政府這些人失業
但其實他聯動的經濟上的影響
我後面還造成了其他人的事業經濟變幻
這個都是其實在去年明年一季度下之類的有出現
再加上其實我們現在在一個AI的大碰碼中間
不大碰碼AI的生產力大提升中間
所以AI的生產力大提升中間是一定會造成很多失業
這個是生產力效率提高的本質就是有些人會失業
所以為了這個就業率最後能夠穩定住聯儲
其實上週的時候
那個他是已經說過做這個reserve management
大概是400別鏈
對吧
就40別鏈
reserve management開始做那個做那個短期債的回購
那這個短期債的回購
其實會通過銀行的一些鬆綁傳遞到長期債裡面去
我們也講過長期債的問題
長期債一直只會供應挺多的
因為政府需要花錢
然後financial policy就會代表的那個利率不會太低
但是呢
我對10年期的看法
我覺得10年期也不會太高的
因為銀行的擴表的過程中間
其實雖然它主要是對百里我們叫百里克
就是2年5年這種债券
它的影響會跟它也就是它可以擴表
它可以養圈短期的東西
其實相對來說比較寬裕的
特別是美聯儲現在其實也不是說
就是因為這個400億一個月
而是400億一個月
能夠保證短期的東西穩定
如果短期的東西不準
它可以它可以繼續做更多的量
那麼往長期往中期的那個傳導
其實主要是靠銀行短
就是最終是銀行可以借到短期的流動性
然後它可以去養長券
它可以去買長券
然後它可以槓桿
它可以不算在那個SLR裡面
那麼這個呢
都是今年12月1號
就是可以試運行
明年4月1號好像就可以試運行的
這個比較確定的過程
那麼額外的政策也會慢慢推出
所以我就對於26年來說
26年整體貨幣政策都是寬鬆的
但是這寬鬆的過程在短期內看不到
在這兩個星期看不到
所以這兩個星期市場的
就我們可以看到上週五開始
對於AI的一個調整
然後看到我們今天昨天也是
AI也是基本上都在調整
那個調整是華爾街本質上存在
兩個很大的質疑
一個是對美聯儲的質疑
就是美聯儲
因為它客戶descent的話
大家覺得因為不是一個人兩個人
其實大家希望保持利率比較高
投票票裡面有6票是希望保持
相對來說它是服從
但是它們並不是很積極的
相對來說我們認為是比較陰判的一些人
但是大家兩句話比較嚴重
所以市場對於美聯儲的看法
是認為美聯儲沒有大咬
就是大家低估了美聯儲歌的決心
這個歌的決心
你看決票並不算是一個非常各派的人
包括當特朗普之前一直去說
我要把它翻譯掉
就你不過這樣講到零
選誰上來都不會講到零
但是選誰上來的他都會比較隔
就是我覺得兩個人還在是不是上來
就是他上來也不會像川普一樣講到零
但是誰都會比較隔派的
所以這個是我對美聯儲的一個認識
但是這跟華爾街現在定價的肯定不太一樣
華爾街現在定價就是美聯儲現在分歧
然後聯儲後面很多的作為會受到限制
這是華爾街現在一個定價
華爾街第二個定價就是AR是個泡沫
然後做AI語音的那些語音廠要破產
然後它特別做空的比較多的是AUROCO
然後我這裡沒有掛AUROCO的CDS
然後大家覺得AUROCO因為它的CAPEX太大
然後它後端收到錢從歐巴岩那裡不確定
歐巴岩能不能持續維持這麼大CAPEX也不確定
這個是大家很多人在做空AUROCO的一個很大原因
但是為什麼敢去存在這兩個質疑
這兩個質疑存在的本質是因為現在是真空氣
就是沒有信息能夠報出來
因為沒有信息能夠報出來
所有經濟數據出來只有
要么就是高低LOCK就是正正好好
那市場覺得能夠承受
要么稍微往任何一邊偏差
然後市場就會很敏感
這種情況下就是很容易點
然後大家可以很容易去質疑
但是我個人認為在現在質疑的篡位已經很重了
特別在CDS在那個AUROCO的CDS上
AUROCO CDS當然可以看到一張圖
我這個圖忘記貼上來
但是AUROCO CDS你們可以看得到的是
AUROCO其實它的這個忘記貼了
但是AUROCO的CDS已經快接近08年水平了
但08年的狀態和現在不一樣
現在主要是它對它供specific的認為
它要可能要出問題
但是08年的時候是整個市場
但是不管怎麼說
這個定價對於債券市場
對於快利市場太擁擠了
AUROCO是不會跑產的
就是不會因為這個
當然可以pricing它有這樣的問題
它後端的這個需求是很穩定的
我上次講過關於為什麼
我認為那個OpenIR其實是沒有問題的
OpenIR還有一些那個盈利的數據
它的那個很簡單
它的那個to business to be的這個
erny的數據其實已經超過Palantir
Palantir是1萬億吧
我們已經說1萬億
將近1萬億
那個OpenIR現在5千億
所以你不管是從那個收入角度來說
或者是從它虧錢
to see的虧錢角度
to see的虧錢角度我已經講過
所以一個月的維持成本是1塊5
那個兩個角度來說
那個OpenIR都不會有問題
然後從模型角度
其實模型我額外再提一個吧
就是其實你想那個英偉達的
大家都說GPU便宜啊
我算過一下GPU沒有多便宜
GPU便宜的本質
它是犧牲的那個能效比的
就是這個PW值的
然後犧牲的這個能效比
但你要把這個東西刮開來算的話
其實阿瓦購並沒有那麼便宜
阿瓦購的麻煩也要50%啊
然後它還有潛在等於是幫那個
谷歌做了一個前道
你把那個阿瓦購算進去也要50%
它也得去TSMC有便宜
也得去分現成
那為什麼英偉達的
就是阿瓦購難道設計能力
能夠比那個英偉達強很多
這肯定是不存在的
所以現在整體晶片上來說
你從PW和那個能效比
整個算力中心
你最後希望的設計有限土地
因為這個土地也是有限的
因為不可能到處建的算力中心
你就P一個土地
然後P這個電力下來
建完以後
你肯定要提高這個算力中心的效率
還是英偉達的片其實是最的有效
那麼這個AI的互相之間競爭
最終你說 OpenAI會不會被取代掉
會不會被谷歌幹掉
我覺得是不太會的
雖然現在Mata要買20萬片好像
Mata要買那個TPU
很多人都要買TPU
這個東西deliver都是需要一段時間的
那麼TPU自己 OpenAI自己也可以去做自己的
只是需要時間
TAPOUT這不是一點兩天
那個
所以我意思說
最終你看現在英偉達系
包括Oracle
就是你現在市場的定價機器擁擠
擁擠的意思
就是做空英偉達很多
做空Oracle也很多
這個倉位很擁擠
它在不是一個很大幅度下跌
只是因為現在大家質疑
然後去導致它下跌的時候
它很快會反彈
它反彈情況很暴力
因為你一旦從就像英偉達一樣
英偉達長期有很大的空間
空操空操空操的很多
一旦市場其實它的Ning
沒有特別大的變化
你英偉達你
你雖然說18ANing的預期會變好
但是你說現在英偉和三月份的英偉
有什麼區別
18A的問題
18A好
一年前我們都知道它沒有問題
18A我們一年前都知道它很好
行業裏面全都知道18A不做
18A一批都不做
但是它今年年初還是跌了18塊錢
對吧
因為大家認為它會破產
在定價CDS它會破產
Oracle面臨類似的事情
但是Oracle肯定是不會破產
然後CDS一旦
而且Oracle並不需要像英特爾這樣
這樣這麼長的周期證明
它不是做防水的
它其實只要OpenAI表現出
出個更好的模型
或者大家對於OpenAI的信心
恢復一下
OpenAI明年出一個revenue的數字
對於B端或對於C端的revenue的數字
出來一些這種東西
它都很有可能很快的會溺出來
那麼這個情況下面
當倉位非常非常集中空單就很危險
這個是我更害怕
所以在現在比方說
如果可能會調整的時候比較穩定的
我認為一定是一個
明年確定性最最高的東西
在後年確定確實是沒有什麼確定性的
但是明年它確定性很高
明年N確定性很高
因為現在大家質疑這些AI公司
還有一個問題
就是這個是質疑AI
然後前面是質疑那個美聯儲
會不會加息
還有個質疑就是
質疑Mega 7
質疑Mega 7它會不會
現在你看Tax高已經
Tax到頭會賣了很多
就是相比較來說
Tax和Psychoco的比較
大家沒有那麼喜歡Tax
但其實Mega 7的質疑是在
Mega 7過去三年
它的Revenue基本上增加了100
就是這些公司
然後它同時的話
Margin增加了10%
就是它的毛利率增加了10%
大家沒有人質疑Mega 7
明年還會不會增加
它確實還會增加
就是它的Revenue還是會增加
那現在大家就擔心的是
它的Margin會不會增加
你Margin能夠增加10%
然後還能繼續增加Margin嗎
這是一個競爭性的市場
那麼市場很多時候
就是用這種傳統的眼光
咱看未來的問題
因為在效率沒有增加市場裡面
確實是很難Margin繼續增加
但是因為明年Margin就是要增加
這個是缺貨的市場
就是明年整體Token從Token開始
一直到後面的晶片
到Wafer
然後到Wafer後面subject
騙的那個東西
就是整個行業性的
從頭到底的全部在缺貨
所以大概至少在半導體裡面
我其他的我覺得也還OK
像Google這樣也都OK
那個行業再起來的時候
Margin還會增加
特別是因為它這種還在增加
所以市場上這三個東西的質疑
那麼這三個的質疑
需要有人去給它就是催化劑
然後讓這個質疑消退掉
它的那個空空頭就會很快的
就會快要退掉
那麼但是現在不會短期裡面沒有
所以現在開始真空氣
真空氣衝
12月份我就在說是真空氣
然後我就真空氣到1月份
然後可能到1月份
2月份經濟數就很差
但不太會接近年寶
就是年寶出來的時候很很很難
很難把倉位就是大的空倉
敢去放到一折堵到年寶去
所以我覺得這個是美國的格局
就是明年的格局就是重現
我一直在講就是真空氣裡面
你是會獲得一個買路的機會的
然後明年是一個比較
我覺得是一個偏看好的
還是一個你有時候忘記了
在美國上在中國未必要
我說中國的事
我好久好久不太敢去講中國的東西
這些寫了兩句英文說一說完
那個反正人民日報大家都看到
就是那個習總書記的表態
要因地質疑本質是實施求是
這個是從人民日報上解下來了
就是關於經濟增長
其實說到一句話
就是說經濟增長
我們追求是實實在在
沒有水分的增長
我說中國的事情
我是結合boujie
結合日本央行的江西去講
日本江行大概率明天是會降息的
不是明天19號是8號後天
那個大後天是要降息的
然後那個大家市場定價
降息比較多
因為日本現在出現了通脹
所以大家現在更多的是
它是不是一個連續降息的開始
日本央行會不會採取一個非常強勢的
這個貨幣手段
就更強的貨幣手段
因為畢竟日本是
我們上周也說到過這個東西
日本是全球的很大的carry trade
測員店
廠商力量還是日本和其他地方是有察覺
你要是真的逆襲了
日本這麼多carry trade
全要on one對市場是一個非常危險的事情
短期裡面對
它會有蠻一部分的
因為現在已經定價的再降息了
定價降息影響就已經體現了
已經在前幾天這種下跌已經體現過
但是那個比歐街會不會繼續去降息
我結合中國的事情講完
因為一句話怎麼說呢
就是心中的成見是一個大山
人總是會被人和國家都是一樣
人國家是人管理的
人總是會被自己過往的一些經歷
受傷的地方所祭拜
中國在八十年代末九十年代初的時候
那個時候那個時點對吧
有很多原因其實是因為通脹
那個八十年代底發生了很大的通脹
那個這個通脹的對於很多現在執政者
是一個是一個痛
是一個就是說不太感覺判的東西
所以中國確實是非常嚴重的通縮
現在中國情況非常嚴重通縮
那麼中國在前一段時間去年眼底到現在
其實到一直到現在
我一直覺得他像那個切爾諾貝利
就是他的通縮採取各種措施
都沒有辦法解決通縮
他把所有的control rock
相當於是我在管理核練長
我把所有的那個控制棒全部給你去掉了
然後希望通縮解決通脹上去還是沒上去
他的結果是完全沒有控制以後
才可能反應都會爆掉
這個是我之前的一個看法
但是因為以前有過這種痛的經歷
所以總書記是比較明智的說
我們現在不要去
就意思就是我們還是要管這個擔心通脹
這個是人心中的一個大煽
那麼事對是挫折包角
因為實際的情況
你有可能會發生這種我剛講的
就是你完全不控制完全失控
因為官僚體系現在很難做到goldlock
就像我們現在希望美國的經濟數據goldlock
美國的管理現在都很難
中國的機制性是非常難以做到goldlock
他要不就往一邊狂奔致死
要麼就手腳拳管住
無人問津也致死
就是因為他的整個中國機制性的傳導
都是以中程為KPI
他不太去管這個經濟最後貴怎麼樣
那麼如果說像去年9月份開始說
我們放水那就往死裡放了
往死裡放的結果
就是可能通常一直起不來一直起不來
忽然起來那就出問題
但是如果現在不是往死裡放了
現在就是要實時代
在最糾沒有水分的增長
就是你們地方政府開工不要給我開了這麼多
然後給我弄些去了吧
腦的這個開工項目
然後最後在那一攤屋伏板
那個不要這麼搞
不要這麼搞的結果呢
就是如果是對於政府的支出有
就是中國如果對政府支出有限制的話
開始有限制的話
那麼這個通縮就是控制不了
因為中國通縮是非常非常嚴重
我們之前講過三個問題
就是人口產能夠甚
然後加上巨大的債務配合房地產泡沫
本地產泡沫破滅的結果
中間巨大的債務
這三個結合在一起
就像他們現在準備出
出他的一些政策提振消費的政策
然後包括給農村的這些社保的政策
這個對於通縮來說
杯水車型一點都沒有
其實甚至我們看到去年9月份開始
讓基礎貨比M0增加了這麼多
快翻倍了
然後都沒有對實際通縮造成很好的控制
這種情況下
他現在出台一些比較定想化的政策
就是會很難的
然後你想一個硬幣的兩面
中國其實當政的一些人
對通縮是有有更生地苦的這種恐懼的
中國對於通脹是有更生地苦的恐懼的
雖然我們現在面臨在通縮中間
但是日本對於通脹是有更生地苦的恐懼
因為他們從90年代開始
通縮從來沒有解決過
印了這麼多錢
把政府的債務搞到這麼高
百分比300多400
全世界最高
不停的國家在回購國債
把自己已經做成流動性陷阱
然後變成全球carry trade的側邊跌
他現在出來一些通脹
然後比歐姐當然需要去控制他
但是更生地苦的日本對於通縮的恐懼是很高高
所以中國和日本我覺得有點像怎麼說的
一個硬幣的兩面
這兩面其實屁股已經決定做到哪裡
但是還是得努力一下
往另外一邊挪一挪
你還是得深一瞎吸
所以我們說比歐姐會不會採取一系列深吸真正去實質性的控制通脹呢
我個人感覺是不太會的
就是他們政策永遠是bias
永遠是怎麼說呢
永遠是傾斜的
他會在同樣的發生通脹和發生衰退的
或者發生通脹和發生就業衰退的情況下
他會先顧就業衰退
他不會先顧就業衰退
這個跟美聯儲有點類似
但是程度會高很多
那麼這個是他永遠是那個傾斜性的政策
就是那個傾斜性不對等的政策
那麼在中國上面
我本來是以為他們最終
什麼好歹去年年底想通了
我們就是要先去把經濟問題解決掉
現在老百姓有口飯吃
其他事情完整來說
那那就看他們變化了
因為中國確實根深蒂固的有通脹後去
那就看昨天
我以為那個
那就先不講中國的事情
我剛剛看到好像有提示
那我們今天先講到這
然後我們看看有什麼問題